bonjour à toutes et à tous j'espère que
cette fois-ci leçon fonctionne je crois
que ma vie' à l'image des sans le son la
première fois est décidément l'image
sans le son vous auriez cru que c'était
la prolongation du discours de jean noël
que je tiens d'ailleurs à saluer
cherchant noël j'ai aimé ce que tu as
dit j'ai aimé des références celle aussi
longs notamment et j aimais les
priorités que tu as apporté pour les
mois qui viennent je crois que là aussi
nous rentrerons est donc un salut amical
à toi et à toutes celles et ceux qui
sont derrière votre écran merci de
m'avoir invité à participer à ces
journées à cette cité démocrate qui est
un beau nom
je tiens moi aussi adressé un salut à à
toutes celles et ceux qui rendent si le
moment possible on le sait avec ce virus
vous avez vu la grande clairvoyance
d'inventer un format nouveau je pense
que c'est aussi le rôle des formations
politiques que d'essayer des choses et
je crois que vous l'aviez fait avec
beaucoup d'anticipation et une nouvelle
fois le modem a été être clairvoyant sur
ce sur ce sujet là je veux dire
peut-être pour commencer que j'ai
plaisir même à distance avoue savoir les
uns et les autres dernière votre écran
parce qu'il ya entre nous et parfois ça
ne semble pas dans la vie politique
l'essentiel mais pour moi ça l'est des
relations qui sont simplement des
relations de parti à parti mais qui sont
souvent des relations plein d'amitié et
de respect je veux saluer françois je
veux savait évidemment aujourd'hui plus
affectueusement encore marielle je vous
salue et toutes celles et ceux au fond
avec qui je et nous travaillons bien au
quotidien
je pense à toi là jean noël évidemment
je pense à marc je pense à fric je pense
à jacqueline je pense à sa rage pense à
nathalie mais je pense aussi à mes
collègues députés aux députés européens
en sénateurs j'ai plaisir à travailler
avec vous et je crois que dans la vie
politique ça compte ses relations là ça
compte aussi
dans les moments qu'ils sont
parfois des moments difficiles bien sûr
nous vraiment partagé ensemble des
victoires une grande victoire notamment
été fondatrice pour permettre ce
quinquennat mais nous avons vécu ces
derniers mois aussi des moments plus
difficiles des moments où il y avait ici
ou là des divisions départ nous devions
avoir entre nous des discussions
difficiles et je crois que
particulièrement dans ces moments là eh
bien ça content d'avoir au fond l'envi
de travailler ensemble et cette envie là
je voulais la partager avec vous parce
que elle est pour moi profondément
inscrite et je pense qu'elle est
réciproque nous allons avoir besoin de
faire vivre cette envie de travailler
ensemble dans les mois qui viennent
peut-être tout simplement pour nous
mettre à la hauteur de la situation et
dans cette rentrée politique je crois
qu'il ya beaucoup de contrastes
justement à ce titre là entre le visage
que montre nos positions aujourd'hui je
suis frappé dans ce moment de rentrer
politique par les profondes divisions
qui reprennent
nous nous sommes convergent dans safran
serait politique nous avons affiché leur
envie de faire ensemble et nous l'avons
dit façon crois que c'est très important
et que ça dénote d'une certaine façon il
ya d'un côté la rentrée de ceux qui le
font au nord particulièrement dispersé
cette année ce qu'ils vont manger des
huîtres ceux qui vont gravir des
collines ou que sais-je encore pour
faire vivre
finalement le combat des chefs avec
l'obsession de 2022 ou plus à gauche des
divisions qui sont en réalité des
divisions extrêmement profonde qui n'ont
pas été réglées entre les différentes
formations de la gauche sur des sujets
aussi cruciaux l'europe ou le rapport à
la république que la mondialisation que
la place de l'entreprise
et bien sûr tout cela je prends que nous
nous partageons beaucoup et nous devons
faire vivre ce contraste là parce que
cette situation politique elle est très
contrasté avec ce que sont les attentes
de nos concitoyens je crois profondément
que nous considérons donc que faire de
tout cela
ils sont aujourd'hui dans des sujets
beaucoup plus fondamentaux sur la
situation sanitaire bien sûr sur la
situation économique
et nous nous devons nous mettre à la
bonne hauteur et portait aussi le
message que ces derniers mois ces
dernières années nous avons en réalité
été à la hauteur de la situation d'avant
été à la hauteur des engagements nous
avions pris en 2017 j'ai eu l'occasion
de le rappeler ces derniers jours mais
si nous n'avions pas fait ce que nous
avons fait depuis trois ans alors je
crois que notre pays aurait été beaucoup
plus affaibli beaucoup moins robuste
pour faire face à la crise
nous avons été à la hauteur de la crise
et cela je crois que nous vous devons
aller le dire à son prêt ferme ce
gouvernement cette majorité a été à la
hauteur de la situation nous avons
protégé les français protéger l'emploi
le pouvoir d'achat des français et de
stahl aussi nous ne devons pas bougé et
puis enfin avec cette nouvelle phase qui
s'ouvre avec le plan de relance une
phase importante pour relancer mais
aussi reconstruire transformer notre
pays je pense pouvoir dire que nous
sommes à la hauteur de nos ambitions
pour le pays et cela vous devrez aussi
le porter ensemble mettons nous à la
hauteur tout simplement parce que tout
ce qui dans la vie politique ressemble
finalement à la vie partisane
je crois profondément que cela nous a
baisse alors que au contraire nous
devons nous élever nous élever et nous
rassembler c'est ma conviction profonde
pour d'abord une raison extrêmement
simple
j'ai la conviction et on a vu ces
derniers mois que à chaque fois que nous
avons montré des divisions au sein de la
majorité présidentielle ou même au sein
d'une formation politique
alors nous avons été en incapacité de
nous faire entendre à nos concitoyens
je crois que notre capacité à nous faire
entendre qui est rare dans la vie
politique
eh bien elle passe évidemment par le
rassemblement par la construction de
cette maison commune font que le
président de la république nous invite à
construire et à faire vivre ensemble
cette maison que me net voir incarner
l'esprit de dépassement nous avons les
uns et les autres vous utiliser ce terme
ces derniers jours c'est un terme
auxquels nous sommes attachés à ce que
au fond c'est ce qui a été fondateur de
notre aventure politique comme je crois
que c'est ce qui a motivé cette aventure
politique françois bayroux évidemment a
été le premier à la faire vivre et à
avoir l'esprit de dépassement en
rejoignant le candidat est maintenant
président de la république en 2017 et
bien cet esprit de dépassement
nous devons continuer à le faire filmer
pour moi l'esprit de dépassement
c'est le contraire de l'esprit de clan
je vois bien que il ya des tentations
aujourd'hui elles viennent notamment de
la droite de le dire que le président de
la république devrait être celui
rappelant le candidat plan je crois
profondément
le contraire je crois que nous devons
continuer à faire vivre cet esprit de
dépassement qui n'est pas un esprit
clanique l'esprit de dépassement n'est
pas non plus un esprit d'effacement je
pense que c'est extrêmement important de
se le dire entre nous je crois que cette
maison commune que nous devons
construire ensemble
elle doit être jean noël le rappeler à
l'instant respectueuse des sensibilités
des histoires des spécificités de
chacune des organisations qui la
composeront et je pense que il faut que
nous puissions accepter cela et nous
devions vraiment faire un des points
fondamentaux parce que sinon nous
annulerons finalement ce qui fait notre
force c'est à dire aussi la capacité par
le débat par les nuances à apporter des
choses plus puissante et à donner plus
d'élan au fond à ce que nous devons
construire et puis cet esprit de
dépassement
ça ne va pas être l'esprit d'enfermement
nous devons continuer à ouvrir d'autres
maisons communes il pas le faire je
reprend très exactement ce que disait
françois la semaine dernière qui nous a
fait le plaisir de venir parler à bien
tu le disais très bien françois ça doit
pas être qu'une affaire de partis
politiques tout ça bien sûr qu'on va
rassembler les formations politiques qui
ont envie
vous dire faire avec nous qui devons
faire notamment au moment des élections
européennes
mais on doit dépasser cette vision là je
crois que la construire de façon
beaucoup plus riches
je me disais avec des think tanks avec
des intellectuels avec des élus avec des
associations d'élus avec les gens de
bonne volonté qui ont envie de venir
faire avec nous et de se mettre là
encore au bon niveau de responsabilité
alors nous allons avoir des travaux
pratiques et nous allons donner coeur
dans un premier temps en agissant à
cette maison commune
nous le ferons dont les assemblées ne
feront à l'assemblée nationale ça sera
le travail de patrick puis nous avons un
nouveau président de vos peuples
christophe qui le fera avec lui avec
olivier également pour donner plus de
fluidité plus d'efficacité au travail
que nous devons faire le feront je
l'espère aussi au sénat en permettant à
toutes celles et ceux qui soutiennent la
majorité présentielle au fond de mieux
travailler ensemble et c'est l'esprit
d'ailleurs dans lequel nous avons
préparé ensemble ces élections
sénatoriales
et puis nous le ferons bien sûr aussi en
préparant ensemble de vos futures
échéances électorales
normal le mentionnait il y a la volonté
je crois très ferme des uns et des
autres de travailler ensemble à cette
échéance là et singulièrement à
l'échéance en régionale je me suis
souvenu de ce que je disais l'année
dernière à guidel quand vous m'avez fait
l'honneur de m'inviter pour mes freins
pour la première fois devant vous vous
avez dit aux élections municipales je
crois qu'on peut assumer l'idée qu'on ne
sera pas d'accord partout parce que
c'est impossible d'être d'accord partout
il ya ici ou là des histoires des choses
qui font que au fond ne pas être
d'accord à 100% est partout mais plus le
mandat avancera plus les échéances
électorales avant seront moins nous
aurons droit de ne pas être d'accord et
bien je crois que on est à ce moment là
où il faut absolument non pas par les
tactiques mais parler stratégie voire et
réfléchir à ce que nous voulons proposer
région par région et ces choix là nous
devons les faire ensemble avec à mon
sens une conviction qui est de ne pas se
tromper d'élection
j'entends bien et s'adresse fleury
d'articles dans ce sens là qui montrent
que les uns et les autres au fonds
envisagent l'exemple régionales comme le
premier tour de l'élection
présidentielle comme la primaire de leur
formation politique je crois que ce
serait une erreur profonde que de
l'envisager comme ça nous ne devons
porter intérêt général
nous devons porter l'enjeu de relance le
premier ministre s'exprimera je le salue
si tu m'écoutes à cet instant tout à
l'heure il porte avec le gouvernement le
plan de relance
ils portent cette ambition de
transformation pour le pays eh bien oui
nous aurons besoin de régions avec
lequel le gouvernement travaillera main
dans la main pour réussir cette relance
et je prends après sa droite est l'enjeu
central du scrutin régional au fond
est-ce que nous va pas revenir dans les
mois qui viennent à faire en sorte que
les 100 milliards de ventes nous avons
mis sur la table pour transformer le
pays il puisse se concrétiser
devenir réalité dans la vie de nos
concitoyens
eh bien nous aurons besoin de faire et
je reprends une expression de patrick
que j'apprécie la relance économique
régional
je pense que ce sera l'enjeu et les lis
que nous devons être ensemble deux vont
être ses listes de la relance et devront
faire revenir l'esprit de renaissance
que nous avons fait vivre aux élections
européennes donc ces travaux pratiques
et nous permettront de continuer à
avancer de continuer à construire cette
maison commune et au fond je voudrais
conclure parlant à faire vivre notre
différence et notre singularité dans la
vie politique du pays là où les autres
ne pense aujourd'hui qui à 2022 je crois
profondément que l'on doit être
concentrée sur les semaines qui viennent
sur ce qu'ils sont les points
d'attention de nos concitoyens là où les
uns et les autres ne pense au fond qu
alors parti à la façon de faire renaître
si cela est encore possible nous ne
devons penser copine et je suis
singulièrement je suis
complètement convaincu que si nous
arrivons à nous concentrer et à faire
vivre cette différence là alors nous
aurons encore la capacité d'être
entendus par nos concitoyens et de
continuer à transformer le pays comme
nous avons commencé à le faire ensemble
depuis trois ans merci à nouveau pour
votre invitation
je vous salue et j'ai hâte de vous
retrouver physiquement par par la suite
bonne journée à tous et monsieur le
président je crois que vous exprimez
donc je vous salue également